we have an update to a story that we
told you about yesterday a young woman
in bridgeport connecticut who died last
month under very suspicious
circumstances
lauren smith fields was found in her
apartment by the man she had had a date
with the night before her family accuses
police of mishandling this investigation
newly released autopsy results conclude
that her death was quote an accident
elise preston is here with more on the
story you're back again from yesterday
elise it's very troubling the more we
hear the worse it seems to get it's very
concerning good morning gail preliminary
results from the state paint the first
real picture of how smithfield died the
medical examiner found smithfields died
of acute intoxication from a combination
of drugs and alcohol the results showed
fentanyl in her system along with two
other drugs the autopsy says the
combination of those substances with
alcohol led to what it calls an
accidental death in a video statement
last night the family attorney said they
believe there was foul play
someone introduced those drugs to her
system
and it wasn't her and we want answers
right now
now the attorney did not explain how the
family knows she did not take the drugs
herself the man hasn't been charged and
is not considered a suspect so we are
not naming him according to the police
incident report smithfield's date told
police that two spent the night drinking
eating and watching a movie at one point
he said she went outside to meet someone
and later fell ill but the two continued
drinking smithfields allegedly fell
asleep and hours later around 6 30 in
the morning the date says he woke up
next to smithfield's not breathing and
call 9-1-1 the full autopsy results will
not be made public but the family can
request it smith feels his family is
also still waiting on its own private
autopsy results which are expected
within the month this is so troubling
elise because listen the autopsy doesn't
show how the drugs got into her system
so we still don't know that and we are
just to believe what the man says the
man who by the way has not been
identified publicly right he could say
anything he he could say anything we
have not identified him we have reached
we have tried to reach out and make
contact we have not been able to do so
but the family has been questioning from
the very beginning has she been drugged
they found they say they found an
unidentified pill in the home they said
they sent that or they had police take
it for processing we call the state lab
they don't have anything in their
possession related to smithfield's death
and we're not identifying him because
he's not been charged he has not been
charged he is not a person of interest
according to police i think just how the
family responded to how the police
didn't really listen to their calls for
concern is also disturbing elise thank
you